alors il ya beaucoup de médias qui ont
fait les gros titres on va rire à dessus
en révélant que tu avais dit qu'il
fallait qu'on démarre à 21h12 alors on
va on va se mettre d'accord tout de
suite avec vincent on a discuté de tout
cet été tous les deux s'appeler plein de
force et appelé way 10 - 10 12 fois
c'est ça ouais et on s'est arrêté sur
21h12 et ça a été transformé il ya eu
entre toi et moi et lionel et la chaîne
le produit 10 minutes de marchands de
tapis
c'est ça ouais j'ai dit j'aimerais qu'on
puisse démarrer l'émission à une heure
fixe alors mais tu m'as dit quelle heure
tu veux démarrer
si on démarre à 21h05 c'est bien et toi
tu as dis non c'est pas possible
21h20 21h10 après 21h15 et aussi arrêté
à 28 ans et c'est pas démarré à 21h12
c'est essayer de faire en sorte que le
programme ne démarre pas après eva était
1h 12 c'est pas du tout je veux que ça
soit 21 ans 12
j'ai eu d'autres exigences qui sont par
exemple je veux absolument non mais
justement temps passant parce qu'on va
l'été ensemble on va faire un vrai faux
tout sur les exigences harada font la
guerre c'est parti elle devrait fournir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je vous l'aï dit à beaucoup de
leaders qui ont révélé des trucs mais
voilà nous on va vous dire toute la
vérité ce soir donc c'est le vrai faux
est ce que vincent lagaf a demandé à
avoir cinq personnes pour s'occuper de
sa coiffure sont bien sûr bien sûr c'est
faux ouah ça est ce que vincent lagaf a
demandé que strike commence
obligatoirement à 21h12 très précisément
dit oui on s'est mis d'accord tous les
deux ce sera 21h12 tous les mercredis on
croit à fond à ce programme qui a déjà
cartonné et je vous le dis il y aura
exactement
pour l'instant il y aura quinze semaines
de strike pendant 15 semaines tournée 30
modules de 40 minutes qui fait 15
émissions 15 émissions donc avec vincent
tous les mercredis vous le retrouverez
pendant 15 semaines et voilà donc il n'y
a pas eu de problème il m'a dit oui je
veux absolument on discute tous les deux
prochains je vous le dis lui et moi et
je voulais dire on discute de tout ça
veut dire on peut même disque rente on
arrive à se parler au téléphone parce
que ça c'est qu'on n'a pas d'éclairage
horaire entre monaco et cavaleur soit
elle ce que vincent lagaf a demandé qu
isabelle morini-bosc pas son avis est
dans sa loge avant le château royal a
demandé mais n'a pas eu malheureusement
elle n'a pas ie n'a pas pu s que ben
sera exigé que fort boyard ne soit pas
diffusée le mercredi sur france 4
oui oui parce que il est dans fort
boyard vincent et cirés qui est des
rowdies de fort boyard et a demandé à la
chaîne ne pas le mettre en face de toi
c'est normal ça me paraît un peu
respectueux par rapport à ceux qui y
travaillent mais en plus c'est
franchement et france téléthon dit oui
ou pas absolument pour disent ok tu as
confiance ou c est ce que vincent lagaf
a utilisé que ces huit produits sa
sextape intitulé chauffe mois les boules
je gère maquis
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors gilles vous n'avez pas compris les
exigences de façon je vais vous
expliquer parce que voilà comme ça ce
sera fait c'est que vincent je leur dis
et je te jure
franchement ça se passe très très bien
entre vincent et moi
vincent je croyais pas qu'il allait tout
autant voilà à l'écouté il écoute la
productrice
il écoute les tout le monde il est il
donne des avis il donne son il donne des
idées
il est passé pas il vient il arrive il
fait son truc et y rentre chez lui et
s'investit pas du tout moi je le dis je
suis très heureux de travailler dans mon
sens que tu investis à fond dans strike
c'est un truc qui compte vraiment pour
toi et quand il fait une émission
il y va à fond il prépare des truies qui
préparent des chorégraphies prépare des
entrées il prépare des vannes c'est un
bosseur et c'est un bonheur de
travailler tôt la jouer il arrive qu'on
soit pas d'accord sur des trucs bas mais
on en parle mais on en parle c'est sympa
mais on se parle de tout avec vinci à
aucun moment il ya une prise d'otages à
aucun moment il ya exigence non mais
c'est sûr jamais eu une exigence la
seule chose qui m'a fait pas de la peine
mais qui m'est fait chier c'est quand tu
as dit mais qui sait ce mec pour pour
exiger sa d'abord suis que je suis je le
dois à personne je sais d'où je viens et
je sais où je vais et comment j'y vais
c'est dans tes propos c'est la phrase
qui m'a gêné
hélas la phrase qui m'a gêné de
jean-michel c'est que j'ai pris le
boulard non non lorsque je me dis c'est
pas une question de boulard il faut que
je fais je vais répondre à la place de
vincent c'est que vincent je vous jure
il veut il veut que tout soit carré de a
à z c'est un gros bosseur franchement
moi je vous le dit c'est il est pour
vous dire pour penser que france 4 ne
rue diffuse pas fort boyard en même
temps que strike il faut quand même y
penser
et ça ça doit vous faire juste à moi
j'adore voilà parce que billy sur des
petits détails on se met d'accord même
sur les pubs sur les pubs voilà on ne
peut pas laisser n'importe quoi et ben
va même vincent même s'il va le regarder
avec nous on va regarder quel est le
meilleur moment
on a eu on n'était pas content le dit la
vérité du lancement des pubs sur les
premiers numéros ce qui s'est passé sur
la pub c'est qu'on nous avait dit mettez
la pub à telle heure au moment du
chronométrage avec le time code on a vu
qu'on arrivait à peu près à cette
heure-là et on a fait un lancement plus
mesdames et messieurs on se retrouve
dans quelques instants après la pub on
est de retour sur le plateau de strike
et puis finalement ça correspondait pas
à l'heure exacte à laquelle la chaîne
voulait diffuser la pub donc ils ont
taillé dedans et je trouve que ces
partis six étaient pas jolie coque ça
s'arrête c'est bizarre ça reprend alors
je leur ai dit soit vous savez
précisément où on met la pub soit et
c'est ce qu'on a fait je vous enregistre
à quatre coupures tu es dedans vous
choisissez on a réussi à s'entendre
c'était pas une exigence c'est beau
c'est en effet dans le même sens
j'entends parfaitement les explications
de cyril et les vôtres moi je me place
toujours du point de vue du lecteur du
téléspectateur on voit un jour les
exigences de la gaffe alors si c'est les
journalistes oui oui elle en met
d'accord mais on avait débattu de ça et
moi je vous le redis les yeux dans les
yeux j'ai adoré votre retour j'ai
toujours milité pour que vous reveniez à
la télé vous êtes une star mais là ça
m'avait paru des caprices de star et je
n'aime pas ça donc je l'avais dit voilà
c'était une liste et pour moi c'est pas
du perfectionnisme l'oeuf était trop
c'est pour ça que j'avais dit ça je le
retire rien mais si je voulais blesser
sur la phrase mais qui sait je m'en
excuse mais je ne retire rien ce que
j'avais dit voilà mais vous avez tout à
fait raison seulement
c'est vrai que c'est monté par les
journalistes pour faire un petit peu du
sensationnel
il ya aucune exigence en dehors du fait
que je veux qu'ils aient absolument
personne dans les couloirs quand je me
déplace et d'avoir faire seulement une
usine allemande pour me déplacer et
c'est tout sachez que ses
téléspectateurs une affaire donnée aux
réalisé après oui elle hésite bin oui
petite question les vincent tu as donné
énormément de strike la première a fait
un carton à 1 million 400 mille
téléspectateurs
quels sont tes pronostics pour les
suivantes chaque mercredi c'est cette
question là non merci je me donne le
temps de réfléchir et de revient on y
reviendra je vais donner mon pronostique
aussi pour de barmon façon alors oui
j'ai tournent autour du million je serai
très bien et non mais oui je disais que
c'est très intéressant les
téléspectateurs doivent vraiment et
cette émission est très bien parce que
les gens peuvent s'exprimer
et moi j'étais je pensais comme gilles
je l'avais dit aussi moi j'étais étonné
on avait l'impression que c'était pamela
anderson on danse avec les stars étaient
pareilles non mais journalisme et il
avait présenté vendredi vraiment vincent
ça a été je te dis ah oui mais c'est
vraiment le gars je l'appelle je lui lis
les trucs qui me rappelle on se dit on
se dit les choses
il n'y a pas du tout de stars ne se la
raconte pas du tout c'est un truc un
truc et je vais être honnête
une fois on s'est engueulé c'est vrai ça
a été très très loin ouais ouais on
était à deux doigts d un succès il ya
quelques années quand vous aviez fait un
sujet sur les salaires et que gérard
louvin à l'époque avait dit une connerie
grosses comme lui c'est à dire la taille
de la connerie en disant que je gagnais
200000 euros par jour une grosse
connerie clash était parti en colère et
là on s'était pris on ces traces étaient
près de la chaussée mais non c'est par
émission c'est par ce même prix par
semaine lé succès par semaine